we do affordable housing in a way that
is sort of private sector oriented we do
the carrot approach not the stick we
don't tell developers this is what you
have to do we tell developers look we
want to be a part of your Capital stack
we will do you know we'll give you a
dollar for every 15 that you invest in
the product or every twenty dollars your
investment project and the only caveat
for our dollar is you got to maintain
rents at a certain level for a certain
period of time that's it it's a carrot
you want the carrot this is what you got
to do to get it if you don't want it
it's okay so they can build either way
absolutely 100 interesting they can do
Market or if they want to do something
uh different they can do affordable
housing and we have built and we will
build probably between four and a half
and six billion dollars of affordable
housing over the next five to ten years
here in Miami in addition to the supply
foreign
do you get from the Democrats here when
you're doing some of these things so
you're lowering taxes you're putting
police on the street I mean one thing
for sure that I notice here is that when
I go to New York and I see cops all over
the place to me it's a sign that
something is not right right when I go
here and I see cops whether it's in
South Beach or down where I am it's like
oh they're they're patrolling and just
making sure everything's okay it's a
huge difference in mentality and I think
the other difference in my ties we
support them right I think I think in
other cities they don't feel supported
yeah what you got to understand is right
now in in America being a police officer
is the hardest job in America it's
harder than being a roofer okay you've
got there isn't a job in America where
you get paid less money with more
scrutiny and more risk right and more at
stake and being asked to do more things
because now they're being asked to be
social workers I mean it's really really
hard to be a police officer in America
and I think fundamentally number one
they need to be protected they need to
be sort of supported right number two uh
they need to be well paid right like
anybody in life right like you you've
got to support them financially because
they've got to take care of their kids
they want their kids to go to school
just like you do
um and so we've been we've been blessed
and then you have to have a lot of
police officers because it creates a
deterrent effect we've given them a ton
of Technology uh to be uh to help them
leverage their you know their sort of
forced multiplier and all of that has
been incredibly successful in
maintaining our homicide rate where it
is what are some of the stresses of
having all these people move here I mean
house prices for sure you mentioned
they're lower than New York but it's
it's tough to get a place here and one
of the things I'm always worried about
and I I see emails from this is that
people that are the OG Floridians should
have done it right and lived here for a
long time they're suddenly feeling oh we
could get priced out because all of
these rich people from LA and New York
we are a victim of our success yeah
right
um what happens is first of all you have
historic inflation so here's a problem
with governments saying we're going to
solve the the inflation crisis by giving
everybody money right so you are you're
in a level where we're at historic
inflation if you look at Urban America
right now not just Miami Urban America
Rents are up 25 percent or more in every
urban city big city in America Miami is
more like 35 45 why because you layer on
top of that at hyper demand where all
people are just fleeing getting the heck
out of places where they think they're
not wanted or where they think they're
getting taxed to death uh or where they
think the economy is moving away from so
you have to know the feeling you have
all these things happening right and so
that is definitely putting pressure on
Miami no doubt about it I I would be uh
lying if I didn't say that were the case
but what makes us different and why will
we thrive in the in the face of that
stress couple of things one is New York
is completely built out
um I think they built the last building
in Park Avenue in the last 50 years just
got built right uh San Francisco's
artificially constrained right with
their zoning code Miami has the ability
to grow 10x we're in a neighborhood
right now Winwood which has explosive
growth you see it when you walk out you
feel it here you can see it's ready we
have the ability to grow the Delta
between what's built and what can be
built is a ten to one multiple so we can
supply ourselves at a level where um you
know where we can keep prices relative
low we have just to give you some
numbers about 185 000 dwelling units in
the city proper in the pipeline right
now to be built in the next 24 to 36
months we have 47 000 dwelling units so
that's a 25 increase in our entire
building stock so that's number one
number two we do affordable housing in a
way that is sort of private sector
oriented we do the carrot approach not
the stick we don't tell developers this
is what you have to do we tell
developers look we want to be a part of
your Capital stack we will do you know
we'll give you a dollar for every 15
that you invest in the project or every
twenty dollars your investment project
and the only caveat for our dollar is
you got to maintain rents at a certain
level for a certain period of time
that's it it's a carrot you want the
carrot this is what you got to do to get
it if you don't want it it's okay so
they can build either way absolutely 100
interesting they can do Market or if
they want to do something uh different
they can do affordable housing and we
have built and we will build probably
between four and a half and six billion
dollars of affordable housing over the
next five to ten years here in Miami in
addition to the supply can you also talk
about the the home the situation because
there basically isn't a homeless
situation at least compared to other
major cities so Florida it's pretty nice
seems like people would want to come
down here right so don't give away ideas
20 of my audience is homeless so look
we're blessed we have systematically
invested and we did it in a way that was
really smart right so we have something
called the homeless trust and it is a
tax right we don't like to pay taxes but
this is a tourist tax so this is for
people who are coming to Miami staying
in hotels they pay one percent uh on
their bill right and it funds a homeless
trust so basically our visitors not not
our residents are paying this tax our
visitors are basically paying attacks
that goes to help what I call the least
the last and the lost the most uh
marginalized in our community and so you
know what have we done we built a
decentralized set of centers that give
them alcohol uh treatment drug treatment
mental health treatment and vocational
training right in addition to that we're
spending over the next two years about 7
million dollars in a plan that I call
functional zero so we have 640 homeless
right now six four zero according to our
last census that's it that's it that's
it wow but I want to be at zero because
I don't think any city in America has
really chopped big city has really
challenged himself to get to zero and I
think that if we create a model then it
can be certainly um exported right to
the rest of the country that are dealing
with tens of thousands of homeless in
their cities yeah and again this is one
of those things where I just see these
other Mayors it's like why don't you
just look at Miami and fix things I went
to Denver yeah I did not you know Denver
is not San Francisco Denver is not and I
love the mayor of Denver's yeah but I
was like but what's going on here look I
I think I had a mayor and I won't say
who it was from a big city one of the
one of the top 20 cities in America tell
me recently we just waited too long you
know we didn't do what you guys did we
used to have 9 000 homeless we bought it
from 9 000 to a thousand right uh and a
thousand is in the county which is 2.8
million people uh only about 600 of that
thousand is in the actual City proper
which is my jurisdiction so um so we did
it through this decentralized network a
lot of these cities just didn't do it
and then of course we're seeing a lot of
mismanagement a lot of I mean I've heard
some crazy statistics in California
where people are paying like four or
five hundred thousand dollars homeless
or something like that yeah and it's
just money that's there's no controls
it's Rife with you know a variety of
problems and So that obviously is not
going to work uh let's talk a little bit
about the the hurricane situation
because obviously it ended up Hurricane
and ended up hitting Southwest Florida
we're obviously in southeast Florida but
at first it was going to hit here
obviously hurricanes do hit Miami yeah
um you've been you've been tweeting
about it and doing doing all sorts of
stuff
um what do we need to know for the for
the Miami and the future of Miami and
who's going to come down here or to
Florida in general when it comes to
these storms so to be honest and I'm you
know again as President of the U.S
Conference of marriage I was uh I led a
delegation uh to to the Gulf Coast to
see all the cities that were impacted in
the Gulf Coast and it was devastating
and I there's two things that I think
everybody needs to know thing number one
one is for every dollar that we as a
community as a country spend on the
front end in resiliency uh investment we
save seven to eight dollars on the back
end so I was just uh at a podcast today
an interview where they were saying that
Senator Rubio's um advocating for 33
billion dollars of spending for
Hurricane Relief so my point is if we
would have spent 5 billion on the front
end we could have potentially saved 25
to 30 billion on the back end you're
talking about building new structures
I'm talking about things like buildings
that I'm talking about things like like
like Urban reservoirs pumps pumps uh
increased sea walls uh you know backflow
preventers these are all the things that
we're doing in Miami right now okay uh
in Miami we posted Hurricane Andrew
which was in 1992 which was a 200 mile
an hour wind event we basically made
Miami the most win resiliency on the
planet like we're a bunker right the
problem now is water and water volume
what we've seen in the last two years
are two events that frankly are super
frightening
um Ian and Dorian I don't know if you
remember Dorian from a couple years ago
Dorian was a category five that sat on
top of the Bahamas never touched a
continental US that I'm aware of maybe
maybe up North but certainly didn't
touch Florida and It produced 25-foot of
storm surge so Ian has produced 10 plus
foot of storms you're talking about 25
so Mother Nature has just shown us two
massively destructive events that no
city in the world is prepared for you
know period full stop yeah we've got to
start being creative we've got to start
you know one of the great things about
this country is it's Innovative Spirit
right it's it's it's it's ability to
solve problems complex problems right
you know we get thrown challenges uh we
we solve them we're the first country to
invent you know a nuclear bomb you know
during World War II right which
obviously um as you know heinous as it
was we used it and it ended the war
could have say who knows what would have
happened if we did we didn't have that
technology we have always been a country
that finds a way to to solve big
problems and this is a big problem if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell